[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHY LEE: There are times
that you may get frustrated
or you don't even know
what your potentials are.
You know, believe in yourself.
And when the timing
is there, you
know, step out of
your comfort zone
and make the bold decision.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
It's sometimes easier
to question what's going
on and challenge what's
going on by asking questions.
Rather than telling someone,
you know, you're wrong, saying,
how did you make this decision?
What inputs went into that?
AMRUTA JOSHI: Cloud is a
very fast moving business.
We are innovating
on both sides--
on the product side, as well
as on the business side.
To be successful in
a space like this,
we need to be OK
challenging the norms
and being challenged ourselves.
GRACE MOLLISON: Just show that
you have an inquiring mind.
All right, just keep
trying to learn.
MENAKA SHROFF: When
I'm at Google Cloud,
I think about the customers
that I need to represent and ask
questions for.
It's relatively easy
to ask questions,
but it's very important to that
discovery and understanding
what you're representing.
ANAIS HAYES:
There's a huge value
for people coming from
all different backgrounds,
with all different
types of education,
to work in the industry.
If you lined up
100 Googlers, you
would see that
we're all different,
and that we all come
from different countries
and different backgrounds.
And so I think it's incredibly
important to consider the fact
that diversity enable us
to build better technology,
and it's incredibly important.
So that would be the number
one thing that I would say
is do not assume there's
only one profile.
[MUSIC PLAYING]